MICHAEL SIPSER: Hi, folks.
Why don't we get started?
Welcome back.
Good to see you all here.
So I am going to first--
well, we'll recap
what we did last time
and what we're
going to do today.
I'll talk a little bit
about the problem set.
And we'll also have a break,
as requested, halfway through.
So why don't we jump in?
What we did last time was
besides introducing the course,
we introduced finite automata
in regular languages,
which are the languages that the
finite automata can recognize.
We talked about these
regular operations.
Those allow us to build what we
call our regular expressions.
These are ways of
describing languages.
So we have finite automata
can describe languages,
and regular expressions
can describe languages.
And one of our goals is to
show that those two systems are
equivalent to one another,
even though they look rather
different at first glance.
So to move in that
direction, we're
going to prove
closure properties
for the class of
regular languages
over these regular operations.
So we'll show that--
well, we already showed that
any two regular languages
have their union,
also being regular.
And we'll show that for the
other two operations as well.
So let's just look ahead to
what we're going to do today.
We're going to introduce
an important concept which
is going to be a theme
throughout the course, called
nondeterminism.
And having that as a
tool that we can use,
we'll be able to show closure
under concatenation and star,
finishing up what we
started to do last time.
And then we'll use those
closure constructions
to show how to convert regular
expressions to finite automata.
And that's going to be
halfway to our goal of showing
that the two systems are
equivalent to one another.
And the following
lecture, we will
show how to do the conversion
in the other direction.
So I thought we would just
jump in, then, and look at--
return to the material
of the course.
As you remember, we were looking
at the closure properties
for the class of
regular languages.
We started doing that.
And if you recall, hopefully,
we did closure under union.
And then we tried to do closure
under concatenation, which
I have shown here on
this slide, the proof
attempt that we tried
to do last time.
And let's just
review that quickly,
because I think that's going
to be helpful to see how to fix
the problem that came up.
So if you remember, we're
given two regular languages, A1
and A2.
And we're trying to show that
the concatenation language
A1A2 is also regular.
And so the way we go
about all of these things
is we assume that A1
and A2 are regular.
So that means we have machines,
finite automata, for A1 and A2.
We'll call them M1
and M2, that recognize
A1 and A2, respectively.
And then what we
need to do in order
to show the
concatenation is regular
is to make a finite
automaton which
recognizes the concatenation.
And we tried to
do that last time.
So if you remember, that
concatenation machine--
M, we're calling it--
what is it supposed to do?
It's supposed to accept
its input if it's
in the concatenation language.
And that means that the input
can be split into two parts, x
and y, where x is
in the A language,
and y is in the B lang--
y is accepted by M1--
and x is accepted by M1,
and y is accepted by M2.
Sorry I garbled that up.
So x should be in A1,
and y should be in A2.
if you can split w that way,
then M should accept it.
So M has to figure out
if there's some way
to split the input so that
the first machine accepts
the first part,
the second machine
accepts the second part.
And the idea that we came
up with for doing that
was to take these two machines,
build them in to a new machine
M, and then connect the
accepting states for M
to the start state--
connect the accepting states for
M1 to the start state for M2.
Because the idea would be
that if M1 has accepted
an initial part, well, then
you want to pass control
to M2 to accept the rest.
But as we observed,
that doesn't quite work.
Because the first
place to split w
after you found an initial
part that's accepted by M1
may not be the right place.
Because the remainder may
not be accepted by M2.
You might have been
better off waiting
until you found
another place that M1
accepted, later on in the
string, say, over here.
And then by splitting
it over there,
then maybe you do
get successfully
find that the remainder
is accepted by M2.
Whereas if you tried to
split it in the first place,
the remainder wouldn't
have been accepted by M2.
So all you need to do--
M has to know, is
there some place
to split the input so that you
can get both parts accepted
by the respective machines?
The problem is that M might
need to know the future in order
to know where to make the split.
And it doesn't have
access to the future.
So what do we do?
So what we're going
to do is introduce
a new concept that will
allow us to basically get
the effect of M1--
and the-- sort of being
able to see the future.
And that new concept is going
to be very important for us
throughout the term.
It's called nondeterminism.
And so we're going to introduce
a new kind of finite automaton
called a nondeterministic
finite automaton.
And first, we'll look
at that, and then we'll
see how that fits in with the
previous deterministic finite
automaton, that we
introduced last time.
So here's an example.
It's always good to start
off with an example.
Here is a picture of a
nondeterministic finite
automaton.
It looks very similar,
at first glance,
to the former kind, the
deterministic finite automaton.
But if you look a
little carefully,
you see that there are
some key differences.
The most important difference is
that in state q1, for example,
whereas in the machines that
we introduced last time,
there had to be exactly one way
to go on each possible input
symbol so you knew how to
follow along through the machine
it's computing, here
there are two ways to go.
In q1, you can either stay
in a1, or you can go to q2.
That's the essence
of nondeterminism.
There could be many
ways to proceed.
And furthermore, on
q1, if you get a b,
then there's nowhere to go.
So that's also possible
within nondeterminism.
So let's just start
looking at these features.
There are multiple
paths forward--
multiple paths possible.
You might be able to have
one, as we had before,
or many ways to go at
each step, or maybe 0 ways
to go at each step.
Those are all legitimate for a
nondeterministic machine, which
is doing a nondeterministic
computation.
Another difference,
if you look carefully,
is that we're allowing
here the empty string
to appear on a transition.
That's perhaps a
little less essential
to the spirit of nondeterminism.
But it's going to turn out to be
a convenience when we actually
apply nondeterminism
to build machines,
as you'll see very shortly.
Now, if there are many
different ways to go--
and some of those ways to go
might have different outcomes.
As we remember from before,
we accepted the input,
if you end up in
an accept state,
and we rejected the
input, if you end up
not in an accept state,
in a non-accepting state.
Then you reject.
But now there might be
several different ways to go.
And we'll do an
example in a minute.
But there might be several
different ways to go.
And they might disagree.
Some of them might accept.
Other ones might reject.
So then what do you do?
Well, in that case, acceptance
always overrules rejection.
That's the essence of
nondeterminism the way
we're setting it up.
You may ask why that is.
And the spirit of that will
become clear in due course.
But right now, just
take it as a rule.
When we're having a
nondeterministic machine,
acceptance overrules rejection.
So as long as there is--
one of the possible ways
to go ends up at
an accept, we say
the whole thing is accepted.
The only way we can
possibly reject--
if all of the possible ways
to go end up at rejection,
end up at a non-accept state.
So we'll see example of--
I think we're going to do
an example right now, yeah.
So if we take, for example, this
machine N1 now on an input ab--
and we're going to process
the symbols one by one,
just like we did before.
But now, to follow along, there
might be several different ways
to go.
So if we take the first symbol
a, and we run the machine--
so when the machine, it starts
at the star state, as before--
but now an a comes in.
And there might
be two-- now there
are two different ways to go.
So we're going to keep
track of both of them.
After the machine
reads an a, you
can think of it as being in
two states now simultaneously.
It can be in state q1,
and it can be in state q2.
So those are two
different possible places
it could be at this moment.
OK?
Now we read the
next symbol, the b.
And from a b, you take
each of the places
where the machine could be at
the end of the previous symbol,
and you then apply reading
a b, the next symbol,
from each of those states
where the machine could
be in from the previous symbol.
So the machine could be in
q1 and q2 after reading an a.
Now we apply a b.
Well, q1 on a b goes nowhere.
So you think of that branch,
if you will, of the computation
as just dying off.
It has nowhere to go.
It just vanishes.
However, the other possibility,
which was state q2 on a b,
does allow, does have a place.
So the machine is now
going to go from q2 to q3
on that branch of the
computation, which
reading-- on reading a b.
And then it has, coming out
of q3, there are two symbols.
There's an a and an
empty string symbol.
Now, on an a, the machine would
have to read an a in order
to transition along that arrow.
But when there's an empty
symbol on the arrow,
that means the machine can
go along that arrow for free
without even reading anything.
As long as it gets to q3, it
can automatically jump the q4.
And so once it has read
a b and gone to q3,
now it can either
stay in q3, or it
can go along the empty
transition and go to q4.
So again, it is going to
be a nondeterministic step
at this point.
The essence of having
a empty transition
is that there is going
to be nondeterminism.
That's why we didn't
introduce that
for deterministic
automata, because you
don't have to transition along
an empty string transition.
You can stay where
you are, or you
can go along the empty
string transition
without reading any input and go
over to the next state, which,
in this case, is q4.
So let's just see where we are.
After reading an a,
we're in states q1, q2.
But now after reading a b,
we're in states q3 and q4
as possibilities.
And now we're at the
end of the input,
and we look and see what we got.
If any one of the
states as possibilities
that we are right now
at the end of the string
is an accept state, then we
say, overall, the machine
has accepted.
So that corresponds to what
we said over here before--
accept the input if some
path leads to an accept.
So if any way of proceeding
through these nondeterministic
choices will lead you to an
accept, then you will say,
we're going to accept the input.
OK?
So this input here is accepted.
Let's do another example.
Suppose we have the
input aa instead of ab.
So aa, after the
first day, as before,
we're in states q1 and
q2 as possibilities.
Now we read an a again.
Now, the one that's on
state q1, that possibility,
q1 possibility,
after reading an a,
it again branches to q1 and q2.
So we know after
reading the second a,
we're going to be in
at least q1 and q2.
Now how about the state that
had been on q2 on reading
an a, the one from before?
After reading the first
a, you were in q2.
Now reading the second
a, there's nowhere to go.
So that one just gets removed.
So after reading aa, we
remain in states q1 and q2
as possibilities.
Neither of those
are accept states.
So therefore, on input
aa, the machine rejects.
OK?
Let's just do a couple more,
and then I'll ask you to do one.
So we have aba as an input.
Let's see what happens then.
So remember, after reading
ab, the machine is in the two
states q3, q4 as possibilities.
That's what we have
from the first example.
So after reading ab,
we're in states q3, q4.
Now we read another a.
The q4 on an a
has nowhere to go.
In fact, it has nowhere
to go in any input.
So no matter what comes in
after you're in state q4,
that branch dies.
But on q3, which is another one
of the possibilities reading
an a, it can follow
along, just transition.
Because that's one of the
labels on that transition, is a.
So you can follow along
just in transition
on reading an a, which is the
last symbol in the string.
And so now after aba, you are in
only state q4 as a possibility.
But that happens to be an accept
state, so the machine accepts.
OK.
And now lastly, let's
take our final example.
What happens if we have abb?
So as we remember before,
after reading ab--
that was the first example--
we were in states q3,
q4 as possibilities.
Now we read a b.
Well, neither of those states
have anywhere to go on a b.
So now all threads, all
branches, of the computation
die off.
And at this point, the
machine is totally dead.
It has no active
possibilities left.
So certainly, it's going to
reject this input, because none
of the active states--
there are no active states
or accepting states.
And in fact, if you looked
at anything that came later,
anything that extended
the string abb
would also be rejected.
Because once the
machine had all--
all possibilities
have died off, there's
no way for them to come back
to life on any extensions.
So with that-- oh,
here's an important point
before I'm going to jump
to a check-in on you.
But I think one
thing that might be
on your mind about
this nondeterminism
is how does that
correspond to reality?
Well, it doesn't.
We're not intending
for nondeterminism
as we're defining
it to correspond
to a physical device.
But nevertheless,
as you'll see, it's
a very mathematically useful
concept, this nondeterminism.
And it's going to be playing a
big role throughout the subject
as we'll experience it
during the rest of the term.
So with that, I'm going
to have a little check-in.
I'm going to ask
you to consider what
happens on one of the inputs.
So here we go.
What does it do on input aab?
So here's the machine.
You can look at it.
And suppose, hopefully,
there's a poll here
for me to give to you so
you can give me your input.
So what does the
machine do on input aab?
Most of you have answered.
Again, you're not
going to be penalized
for getting the wrong answer.
But hopefully, you'll
get the right answer.
Anyway, let's just
take a look here.
So time is up.
Let's end the polling
and share the results.
So the majority of you,
majority have gotten
the correct answer, which is a.
The machine does accept aab.
Because when you have a--
so I'll show you the path
that corresponds to accepting.
You go a, a, b, and
then empty string.
And so that sequence
of steps is one
of the nondeterministic
possibilities
that the machine can follow.
And that shows that the machine
does accept the input aab.
You can think about it, the
way we did it before also.
If you read an a, it's in
the two possibilities q1, q2.
You read a second a, again,
in the possibilities q1, q2.
Now you read a b.
It's in the
possibilities q3, q4.
And that's it, aab.
So now you read the b.
It's in possibility q3, q4.
q4 is an accepting state.
That overrules the
non-accepting state.
And so the machine accepts.
You have to understand this.
So if you didn't get
it right, go back
and think about
where you slipped up.
OK?
Because this is
just getting-- we're
just getting warmed up here.
It's going to get a lot harder.
OK, so stop sharing the results.
And so let's continue.
So just as we did last
time, we can formally
define a nondeterministic
finite automata.
Here's the picture again.
OK.
So it looks a lot like
the case we had before,
the Deterministic
Finite Automata, or DFA,
as we'll call them.
It's a 5 tuple.
So I've written down
little reminders
for what those components
of that 5 tuple
are, that list of
five components.
So they're all the
same as before--
states, alphabet, transition
function, start state,
and accepting states.
So that the formal
definition looks
exactly the same except the
structure of the transition
function.
So now, before, if
you remember, you
had a state and an input symbol,
and you got back a state.
Now we have something
more complicated-looking.
We have a state and
an input symbol,
but instead of just sigma,
it's sigma sub epsilon.
And that that's a shorthand
for sigma union epsilon.
And that's a way-- my
way of saying that you're
allowed to have
on your transition
arrows either an input
symbol or an empty string.
So the transition
function has to tell you
what to do when you have an
empty string coming in as well.
So that would be part of
your table for the transition
function.
Now, over here, what's
going on over here?
Well, now, instead of just
producing a single state, when
you've read, for
example, an a from q1,
there's a whole set
of possibilities.
So here we have what's
called a power set.
That's the set of subsets
of the collection Q.
So here we're going to produce
an entire subset of states.
Instead of just one
state coming out,
there might be a subset
of possible states
that you can go to.
So the power set of Q is
a set of subsets of Q.
So that's what this
notation means.
Again, this is something that
I'm, hopefully, presenting
to you as a bit of a reminder.
You've seen this
somewhere else before.
But please make sure you
understand the notation,
going forward, because we'll
be doing less hand-holding
as we start moving forward.
OK.
So just let's take a look.
In the N1 example here, just
to illustrate what's going on,
when you're in state
q1 reading an a,
now you get a whole set
of possibilities, which,
in this case, is q1 and q2.
Whereas, if you're reading
a b, what would be that set?
Coming out of q1, what's the set
of possible successor states?
Well, there are none.
So it's the empty set.
OK?
So hopefully, you're
understanding the notation
here.
So now here's, I think,
really important.
How do we understand
nondeterminism, intuitively
speaking?
And there are multiple
different ways,
which each has their value
under different circumstances.
So one way is thinking
about nondeterminism
as a kind of parallelism.
So every time the machine
has a nondeterministic choice
to make, where there's
more than one outcome,
you think of the machine
as a branching, forking,
new threads of the parallel
computation at that stage,
where it makes an entire
copy of itself when there's
a choice of possibilities.
And then each of
those independently
proceeds to read the
rest of the input
as separate threads
of the computation.
So if you're familiar
with parallel computing,
this should be reasonably
familiar to you.
The only key thing
to remember is
that as this thing forks
a number of possibilities,
the acceptance rule is, that if
any one of those possibilities
gets to an accept at the end
of the input, it raises a flag
and says, accept.
And that overrules
everybody else.
So acceptance dominates.
So another way of looking at
it is the mathematical view,
where you can imagine-- and
we're going to use all these.
So you really need to
understand them all.
The mathematical
view is you can think
of the computation as kind
of a tree of possibilities.
So you start off at
the very beginning
at the root of the computation,
which is when it really begins.
But every time there's a
nondeterministic branching
that occurs, that
node of the tree
has multiple children
coming out of that node.
And so the different
threads of the computation
correspond to different
branches of that tree.
And now you're going to accept
if any one of those branches
leads to an accepting state--
OK, obviously, somewhat
similar to what we had before.
But I think it's a little bit of
a different perspective on how
to think about nondeterminism.
And the last one is going
to sound a little weird.
But actually, I think for
people who are in the business,
it's the one they use the most.
And that's the magical way of
thinking about nondeterminism.
And that is, when the machine
has nondeterministic choices
to make, you think
of the machine
as magically guessing the
correct one at every stage,
and the correct one being
the one that will eventually
lead it to accept.
OK?
So you can think of
the machine as guessing
which is the right way to go.
And if there is some
way right way to go,
it always guesses right.
Of course, if the machine
ends up rejecting,
because there is no right way
to go, then it doesn't matter.
There is no good guess.
But if there is some good guess,
we'll think of the machine
as taking that good
guess and going that way.
OK.
So now here is a
very important thing.
We introduced this new model,
the Nondeterministic Finite
Automaton, NFA.
It turns out, even though
it looks more powerful,
because it has this
nondeterminism,
it isn't any more powerful.
It can do exactly the
same class of languages,
the regular languages.
And we'll show that
with this theorem
here, that if an NFA recognizes
a, then a is regular.
So we'll prove
that by showing how
to convert an NFA to an
equivalent DFA, which
does the same language.
So we can take an NFA that
has the nondeterminism
and find another DFA which
doesn't have nondeterminism,
but does the same language.
It accepts exactly
the same strength,
even though it lacks that
nondeterministic capability.
This is going to be
extremely useful, by the way,
and for example, in showing that
closure under concatenation.
OK, so in this
presentation here,
I'm going to ignore the
epsilon transitions.
Because once you get the
idea for how to do this,
you could figure out
how to incorporate them.
They just make things a
little more complicated.
So let's just focus on the key
aspect of nondeterminism, which
is that the machine could
have several ways to go
at any point in time.
There could be several
next states on an input.
OK?
Now the idea for
the construction--
so we're going to start with
a nondeterministic machine M,
and we're going to build
a deterministic machine
M prime, which does
exactly the same thing.
And the way M
prime works is it's
going to do what you would
do if you were simulating
M. What would you do?
This is what we were doing as
I was explaining it to you.
If you were simulating M, every
time you get an input symbol,
you just keep track of what
is the set of possible states
at that point in time.
That's what the
DFA is going to do.
it's going to have to keep track
of which possible set of states
the NFA could be in at
the point on that input
where we are right now.
And then as you get
to the next symbol,
the DFA is going to have to
update things to keep track
of the next set of states the
NFA could be in at this point,
just like you would do.
OK?
And so here's a
kind of a picture.
And how do we implement that?
So here's the NFA that
we're starting with, M,
and we're going to
make here the DFA.
But in order to remember which
set of states that DFA could
be in at a given point-- so
maybe it's in the set of states
that M could be in.
Did I say it wrong?
Which set of states the NFA
could be in a given time--
so maybe M, the
NFA, could be in,
at some point, state q3 and q7.
The way the DFA
keeps track of that,
it's going to have a state for
every possible subset of states
of the NFA.
That's how it remembers which
subset of states the NFA is in.
That's the way DFAs work.
They have a separate
state for each possibility
that they need to keep track of.
And the possibilities here
are the different subsets
of states that the NFA could
be in at a given point.
OK?
So corresponding to this subset,
to these two possibilities
q3, q7, the DFA is going to have
a state with the subset q3, q7.
And it's going to, for
every possible subset
here, there's going to be a
different state of M prime.
So M prime is
going to be bigger.
OK.
So quickly, the construction of
M, the states of M prime now,
q prime, are going to be the
power set, the set of subsets
of states from the
original machine M.
And now we have to look at
how the transition function
of the DFA, when you
made the primed machines
of the DFAs, the DFA machine.
So these are the
deterministic components.
So delta prime, when it has a
subset, something like this,
has one of its states,
which corresponds
to a subset of states of M,
and it reads an input symbol,
you just have to do the updating
the way you would naturally do.
You're going to look
at every state in R,
look at where that
can go under a--
so there's a bunch
of sets there.
And look at all
the possible states
that could be in one
of those subsets,
and that's the set of
states that you could be.
That's going to be
the new set of states,
and that's going to be in
the new state of M prime.
OK?
So it's going to be the
subset corresponding to all
of the states that could be in,
when you apply the transition
function of the
nondeterministic machine,
to one of the states
in the subset of states
that the nondeterministic
machine could be in.
OK?
It's a little bit of a mouthful.
I suggest you look at
this, if you didn't quite
get it, after the fact.
Good to understand.
The starting stage for the NFA--
for the DFA-- I'm
sorry-- is going
to be which subset now we're
going to start off with.
It's going to be the subset
corresponding to just the start
state of M. And the accepting
states are going to be--
of the deterministic machine are
going to be all of the subsets
that have at least one
accepting state from the NFA.
OK?
So I hope you got that.
Because I'm going to give you
another little check-in here.
Which is I'm going to ask
you, how big is M prime?
How many states
does M prime have?
I told you what
those states are.
So just go think about that.
So check-in two--
if M has n states,
how many states does M prime
have by this construction?
OK, so let's launch
the next poll.
OK, five seconds-- and I
think we're almost done here.
good.
All right, share results--
I don't know if sharing
results is a good thing.
I'm not trying to
make you, if you
didn't get the right answer--
because most of the people
did get the right answer--
but if you didn't get the right
answer, trying to make you
feel bad.
But it's a little
bit of suggestion
that you need to review
some basic concepts.
So the basic concept
here is if you
have a collection-- you
have a set of states,
how many subsets are there?
And the number of subsets
is going to be exponential.
So if you have a
collection of n elements,
the number of subsets of those
n elements is 2 to the n.
That's the fact
we're using here.
And that's why M prime
has 2 to the n states,
if M had n states.
And you should make sure
you understand why that is.
All right, so with
that, as requested,
we're going to have
a little break.
And that break is going to
last us exactly five minutes.
So we will return
in five minutes.
I'm going to be prompt.
So I gave you a
little timer here.
So please, I'm going to begin
it right when this is over.
OK, almost ready.
I hope you're all refreshed
and ready for the second half.
So now that we have
nondeterminism,
we're going to use that as
a tool to prove the closure
properties that we
were aiming for,
starting from last lecture.
OK.
So remember, let's look
at closure under a union.
Now, we already
did that, but I'm
going to do it again, but this
time, using nondeterminism.
And you'll see how
powerful nondeterminism is.
Because it's going to allow us
to do it almost with no effort.
We'll start off the
way we did before.
I'm going to start
off with two DFAs.
But actually, these
could be NFAs even.
But let's say we started
with the two DFAs
for the two languages A1 and A2.
And now we're going to construct
an NFA, recognizing the union.
And that's good enough,
because we already
know that we can
convert NFAs to DFAs.
And therefore, they do
regular languages, too.
OK.
So now here are
the two DFAs that
do the languages A1 and A2.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put them together
into a bag of states, which is
going to be M, the NFA that's
going to do the union language.
So remember-- what
does M supposed to do?
M is supposed to
accept its input,
if either M1 or M2 accept.
So how is it going to do that?
What it's going
to do, we're going
to add a new state to M,
which is going to branch
under epsilon transitions.
And now you can start to
see how useful these epsilon
transitions are
going to be for us.
Going to branch under
epsilon transitions
to the two original start
states of M1 and M2.
And we're done.
Why?
Well, now, nondeterministically,
as we get an input,
w coming in to M--
and at the very beginning, even
just right after it gets going,
the very first
thing that happens
is it's going to
branch to M1 and also
branch to M2
nondeterministically
as two possibilities.
And then inside M1 and M2,
it's going to actually start
reading the input.
And each one is going to
be now following along
as it would have originally the
states corresponding to reading
those input symbols.
And M, as a combination
of M1 and M2,
is going to have a possibility
for one state in M1
and one state in M2.
And so M is going to have those
combined into one package.
And now at the end of the
input, if either of these end
up at an accepting
state, then M is
going to accept as a
nondeterministic finite
automaton.
Because that's how
nondeterminism works.
You accept if either--
if any one of the
branches ended up
accepting-- which is just
what you need for union.
So when we're doing union,
you want either one of these
to be accepting.
And the nondeterminism
just is built
conveniently to allow us to
do the union almost for free.
So you can again, thinking
about nondeterminism
as terms of
parallelism, you could
think of the
nondeterministic machine
as running in parallel
M1 and M2 on the input.
And if either one of them ends
up accepting, M will accept.
Or you can think
about it in terms
of that guessing that
I referred to before,
which means that
as M is getting--
when it's just about to read
the first symbols of its input,
it guesses whether that's going
to be an input accepted by M1
or an input accepted by M2.
And the magic of
nondeterminism is
that it always guesses right.
So that input happens
to be an input that's
going to be accepted by M2.
M is going to guess that M2
is the right way to follow.
And it's going to go
in the M2 direction.
Because nondeterminism,
the magic
is you always guess right.
I wish that was
true in real life.
It would make
exams a lot easier.
Anyway, so now let's see how
we can use that to do closure
under concatenation.
OK, so now we're
going to actually
have a picture of very similar
to the one we had originally.
But now using nondeterminism,
we can make it work.
So here we have the two machines
doing the two languages, A1
and A2.
And we're going to combine
them into one bigger machine M,
as shown.
Remember, what M
is supposed to do
is accept its input, if
there's some way of splitting
that input, such that the first
half is accepted by the M1,
and the second part
is accepted by M2.
The way we're going
to get that effect is
by putting in a transit empty--
empty transitions,
epsilon transitions,
going from the accept states
of M1 to the start state of M2,
just as I've shown
in this diagram.
So these were the original
accepting states of M1.
And now they're going
to be declassified
as accepting states.
But they're going to have new
transitions, empty transitions,
attached to them,
which allow them
to branch to M2 without
reading any input.
And so intuitively
speaking, this
is going to do the right thing.
Because once M1 has
accepted some part of w,
then you can
nondeterministically
branch to M2.
And you're going to be
start processing inside M2.
And the point is--
I jumped ahead of myself--
is that the reason why it fixes
the problem we had before is
that the epsilon
transitions don't--
the machine does not
have to take that.
It can stay where it is as
one nondeterministic option,
or it can move along
the epsilon transition,
without reading any input,
as another nondeterministic
option.
So it's using this
nondeterminism now
to both stay in M1 to continue
reading more of the input
and to jump into M2 to
start processing what
might be the second half or the
second part of the input which
M2 accepts.
And you can think of it
in terms of the guessing
as that the machine is guessing
where to make that split.
Once it found an initial
part that's accepted by M1,
it guesses that this is
the right split point.
And that passes to M2.
But there might be
other guesses that it
could make corresponding
to other possibilities.
And so with nondeterminism,
it always guesses right.
If there is some way to
split the string into two
parts accepted by M1
and M2, the machine
will make that good guess.
And then M1 will
accept the first part,
and M2 will accept
with the second part.
And we'll get M accepting
that whole string altogether.
And so that is the
solution to our puzzle
for how do we do closure
under concatenation.
OK, I hope that came through.
Because we're just getting
going with nondeterminism.
We're going to be using
nondeterminism a lot,
and you're going to need to
get very comfortable with it.
OK?
Now let's do closure under star.
And closure under star
works very similarly,
but now we're just going
to have a single language.
If A is regular, so is A star.
So they're not a
pair of languages,
because a star is a
unary operation applying
to just a single language.
So if we have a DFA
recognizing A, in order
to show that A
star is regular, we
have to construct a machine
that recognizes A star.
And the machine we're
going to construct
is as before and then an NFA.
OK?
So here is M, the
DFA for A. And we're
going to build an NFA M
prime that recognizes A star.
And let's think now, what does
it mean to recognize A star?
So if I'm going to
give you an input,
when is it in the star language?
What does M prime have to do?
So remember what star is.
Star means you can take
as many copies of you
lot as you like of strings
in the original language,
and that's in the star language.
So to determine if something
is in the star language,
you have to see,
can I break it up
into pieces which are all
in the original language?
So you want to see, can I
take my input w and cut it up
into a bunch of pieces--
four, in this case--
where each of those
pieces are members
of A, the members of
the original language?
So that's what M prime's job is.
It has its input
and wants to know,
can I cut that input up
into pieces, each of which
are accepted by the
original machine M?
That's what M prime does.
And if you think
about it a little bit,
really what's happening
is that as soon as M--
so M prime is going
to be simulating
M. That's the way I like to
think about this, as having
M inside.
So if you were going to
be doing this yourself,
you're going to take w.
You're going to
run it for a while.
You'll see, oh, M is accepted.
Now I have to start
him over again
to see if it accepts
the next segment.
So every time M
accepts, you're going
to restart M to see if it
accepts another segment.
And so by doing that, you're
going to be cutting w up
into different
segments, each of which
is accepted by M. Of
course, it's never totally
clear whether you should,
for any given segment,
you should cut it there or you
should wait a little longer
and find another, a
later place to cut.
But that's exactly
the same problem
that we had before
with concatenation.
And we solved it
using nondeterminism,
and we're going to solve it
again using nondeterminism.
So the way we're going
to get that effect
of starting the machine over
again, once it's accepted,
is by adding in epsilon
transitions that go
from the start states back to--
from the accept state
back to the start state.
So now every time
M has accepted,
it has an option-- not a
requirement, but has an option.
It can either stay
continuing to process,
or it could restart,
making a cut at that point
and trying to see if there's
yet a second, another segment
of the input that
it's going to accept.
And this is basically the whole
thing, with one little problem
that we need to deal with.
And that is we need to make
sure that M prime accepts
the empty string.
Because remember,
the empty string
is always a member
of the star language.
And as it's written
right now, we're
going to be requiring there
to be at least one copy
of at least one segment.
We're not taking into account
the possibility of no segments,
which is the empty string.
And the way we're
going to get that is--
well, I mean, one thing,
one way to get to add--
so we're missing the
empty string right now.
So how do we fix it?
Basically, we're just going to
take the construction we have
on the screen, and
we're going to adjust
it to add in the empty string.
Because it's possibly missing.
One way to do that, which
is tempting, but wrong,
is to make the start state of M
an accepting state for M prime.
So we could have made this
an accepting state, too.
And now M prime is also going
to accept the empty string.
That's the good news.
The problem is
that the start date
might be playing
some other role in M
besides just being the start.
There might be times when M
comes back to the start state
later on.
And if we make the start
state the an accept state,
it's going to suddenly
start accepting
a bunch of other things too,
which might not be intended.
So it's a bad idea to make the
start state an accept state.
Instead, we'll take the
simple solution alternative
of adding a new start
state, which will never
be returned to under
any circumstances,
and make that a new start--
an accept state as well.
So here, we'll have to make
this additional modification.
So as I'm saying, this
is what we need to do.
And the way we'll do that is by
adding a new start state, which
is also an accept
state, to make sure
it accepts the empty string.
And then that also can
branch to start off M
as before, if the string that's
input is not the empty string.
And so then M prime
is actually going
to have to do some work to
see if it can be cut off,
as it was doing before.
So that's the proof
of closure under star.
I'm not going to do it
anything beyond what I've just
described.
These proofs by picture are
convincing enough, I hope.
And if not, they are explained
in somewhat more detail,
somewhat more formally,
in the textbook.
But for the lecture, this
is where I'm going to stop,
with these two arguments.
And so now-- oh, we have
one quick check-in on this.
So if M has n states,
how many states
does M prime have by
this construction?
So I'm not intending these
to be very hard, more just
to keep you awake.
So how many states
does M prime have?
OK, maybe a little too
easy even for a check-in.
Yeah, everybody is
getting this one.
Because all you did was--
we added one new state.
So the answer is as you have--
I think pretty much everybody
is observing that it's number b.
So I'm going to end
the polling, and I'm
going to share the results.
And everybody got that one.
And so let's continue on.
And so the very last thing
we're going to do today
is show you how to convert
regular expressions to NFAs,
thereby showing that
every language that you
can describe with a
regular expression
is a regular language.
On Tuesday, we'll show
how to do the conversion
in the other direction
and so thereby showing
that these two methods
of describing languages
are equivalent to one another.
So here's our theorem.
If R is a regular
expression, and A
is the language--
a set of strings
that that regular expression
describes, then A is regular.
OK?
So we're going to
show how to convert.
The strategy is to convert
R to an equivalent NFA M.
And so we have to
think about, remember,
these regular expressions
that we introduced last time.
These are these expressions
that look like ab union b
star, something like that--
so built up out of
the regular operations
from the primitive
regular expressions
that don't have any operations,
that we're calling atomic.
So if R is an atomic
regular expression,
it just looks like either
just a single symbol
or an empty string symbol
or an empty language symbol.
Or R can be a composite
regular expression--
whoops.
We're having a little--
yeah, so we have two
possibilities here.
R is either atomic or composite.
And so let's look at what
the equivalent expression is
in each case.
So if R is just the single
letter regular expression--
that's a totally legitimate
regular expression,
just a regular expression 1.
So that just describes the
language of the string 1.
So we have to make an
NFA which accepts--
which recognizes
just that language,
accepts only the string 1.
So it's a very simple NFA.
It just starts in
the start state.
And on that single symbol, it
branches to an accept state.
And there were no other
transitions allowed.
So if you get
anything else coming
in besides that one,
that string, which
is just that one symbol, the
NFA is going to reject it.
If it's too long, if
it gets aa coming in,
well, there's nowhere to go from
this accepting state on an A.
So the machine is
just going to die.
It has to be in an accept
state at the end of the input.
Now, I want you think for
yourself for a minute,
how do we make an NFA which
accepts only the empty string
and no other strings?
You can do that with just
one state with an NFA,
just this one here.
The machine is
going to start off
in the start state,
which is also immediately
an accept state.
So it accepts the empty string.
But if anything else
comes in, there's
nowhere to go when
the machine dies.
So this machine accepts
just the empty string.
Or its language is the
language with one element,
the empty string.
How about the empty language?
Well, here's an NFA which
has no accepting state,
so it can't be
accepting anything.
Now, if we have a composite
regular expression,
we're already finished.
Because we showed
how to build up--
we showed constructions which
give us closure under union,
concatenation, and star.
And those
constructions are going
to enable us to build
up the NFAs that
do the language of these more
complex regular expressions
built up out of the NFAs
that do the individual parts.
So if we already have
NFAs that do R1 and R2,
then the closure under
union construction
gives us an NFA that does
R1 union R2 as a language.
So I hope that's
clear, but I'm going
to do an example which will
hopefully illustrate it.
And it's going to show you--
basically, what I'm giving
you is an automatic procedure
for converting a regular
expression into an equivalent
NFA.
So let's just see that
procedure in action,
which is really just
following this recipe
that I described for you.
So here is a regular
expression a union ab star.
So this is a regular expression.
It's some language.
Whatever it is, I don't care.
But I want to make an NFA which
recognizes that same language.
And the way I'm going to
do that is first build
NFA for the components,
the subexpressions
of this regular expression,
and then combine them,
using our closure
instructions, to be
NFAs for larger and
larger subexpressions,
until I get the NFA
that's the equivalent
of the entire expression.
So let's just see how that goes.
So the very most
primitive parts,
the smallest
subexpressions here,
are just the expressions
for a and for b.
So here's the one just for a.
So this is the NFA which
recognizes the language, which
is just the one string a.
Here is the NFA whose language
is just the one string b.
And now I want an NFA which
accepts only the string ab.
Now, of course, you could
just do that by hand yourself.
It's simple enough.
But what I'm arguing is that
we can do this automatically,
using the closure construction
for concatenation.
Because really there's a
hidden concatenation symbol.
This is a concatenate b.
So now for ab, I'm going to take
the thing from a and the part
from b--
so these two things
that I had from before,
and use the concatenation
construction to combine them.
You see that?
So now I have
automatically an NFA
which does the language
whose string is just
ab, just the ab string.
And it's not the simplest NFA.
You can make a simpler one,
but the virtue of this one
is that I got it automatically
just by following the closure
construction.
So now I'm going to do
a more complex one, just
the inside here, a union ab.
So the way I'm going to
build that is from the two
parts, the a part
and the ab part,
the a part and the ab part.
So here is the a part.
Here's the ab part.
I've already got
those from before.
It's really kind of a
proof by induction here.
But I think it's
simple enough, we
don't have to use that language.
So we have the a
part, the ab part.
And now we are going
to apply the closure
under union construction to
combine those into one machine.
And remember how that worked.
We had a new symbol here, which
branches under empty string
to the previous--
we're adding a new
start state, which
branches to the original start
states under empty transition.
And now this is an NFA for
this language, a union ab.
And lastly, now
we're one step away
from getting the star of this.
And how are we going to do that?
We're going to take this thing
here and apply the construction
for the star closure.
And that's going
to be an NFA which
does a union ab
star, which is what
we wanted in the first place.
So first, we're going
to bring that one down.
Because we've already
built that one.
And now remember how we
built the closure under star.
We made the accepting states
return back to the start state,
and we added a new
start state to make
sure we got the empty
string in there that
transitioned to the original
start state under epsilon.
OK?
So that's all I wanted to
say for today's lecture.
Let's do a quick review.
Very important
concept, nondeterminism
and nondeterministic
finite automata--
we proved they were
equivalent in power,
showed the class of
regular languages
closed under
concatenation in star.
We showed how to do conversion
of regular expressions to NFAs.
So I think that is it
for today's lecture.
And thank you, all,
for being here.
I'll try to answer
a few of these.
"Why does concatenation
have order?"
Well, because it's an
ordered construction.
Is there a simple way to prove
closure under concatenation
without using nondeterminism?
No.
"Why are the empty strings
at the accept state?
Can't they be at any state?
Doesn't star make copies
of any part of the input?"
No, it's only-- you have to
think about what's going on.
You have to branch back to the
beginning only on an accept.
Because that means you
found a piece that's
in the original language.
"Is there an automaton
that can add some
or subtract memory automata?"
Well, depends on what
you mean by all that.
But certainly, there are
more powerful machines
that we're going to study
than finite automata.
But yes, there is.
And even finite automata
can add and subtract,
if you present the
input in the right way.
I would refer you to the
first problem on the homework.
So I think I'm going
to check out then.
Take care, everybody.
Bye-bye.